russian missiles struck an apartment
building and resort near the city of
odessa this morning killing at least 19
people according to local officials
rescue crews are working to find anyone
who might be trapped in the wreckage the
attack comes a day after a nato summit
ended in spain with new pressure on
russian president vladimir putin
nato countries pledged further aid to
ukraine more sanctions against russia
and a build-up of military forces in
europe face the nation moderator and
chief foreign affairs correspondent
margaret brennan spoke exclusively with
german chancellor olaf schultz in madrid
about how he's criticizing putin yet
still spending billions of dollars to
russia
germany is providing about 2 billion in
aid to ukraine
that's
roughly what you spend per month on gas
from russia on coal on energy supplies
so while you're helping the ukrainians
financially you're also essentially
giving vladimir putin a financial
lifeline
he cannot buy anything from the money
he's he's getting from us because he
will he has all these sanctions on
imports for modern technologies and
things he is looking for so this is what
is making very angry but vladimir putin
can use that money elsewhere uh just not
in the west but he cannot buy it is it
still two billion a month that germany
is sending to russia it is always
decreasing and then once again say that
we decided that we do the same that we
draft the sanctions in a way that they
hurt putin and this is what we do and
once again we are now doing real
investments into
technology in pipelines in ports
and i know there are people that
sometimes think that when you are having
taking a decision
one afternoon the next morning you have
a port and a 40 kilometers pipeline
in the real life this is not happening
you can see more of margaret's exclusive
interview with the german chancellor on
the only sunday political talk show
worth your time face the nation with
margaret